so you were in Kansas City pre- tailor
preor yes well same same position right
same thing same team yeah same team did
he just break your record Kelsey uh he
broke my record do you have to be
bringing that oh no no thank no no
because you tweeted about it you you did
something about that's how I know yeah
yeah well I'm just Travis Kelsey uh you
said congratulations I think of course
he's such he's such a good dude and the
whole Taylor Swift thing now is uh
comeing to I was in the airport the
other day and this 10-year-old girl
comes up to me and and I don't you know
men usually come up to me football yeah
uh and and occasionally like you know a
woman but a 10-year-old girl I was like
oh how cool I'm getting so popular that
a a 10-year-old girl comes with me she
goes hi is your name Tony and I go yes
it is you know like maybe one she goes
do you know Travis Kelce and I'm
like but I I think it's great that
Taylor's done this for the NFL she's
brought a whole new audience I
will I I will say no that that is and
there's a lot of swifties out there
watching now but I I will say not
because of that but I really got into
football this year like I finally I
think I just broke down because all my
friends and family are into I'm
literally an alone on an island but I am
obsess like I'm in fantasy football
leagues like I love do you do fantasy I
do fantasy I do with my boys My Boy
River and uh and Nico we're in a little
league we both have a river we got the
river right oh my God I'm obsessed with
I almost wish I are you into football I
really like football I I really do I
really like marching bands so I
like is that not cool to admit are you
kidding me the Ohio Michigan game and
how the Ohio comes in it's cool right I
literally just lost my mic pack on that
I like know I got it Rosa I'm putting it
all I'm so bendy
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home